[Musik]
willkommen bei 8
was geht ab herzlich willkommen bei
anleihen video wie ihr seht meine haare
als wenn ich die nicht gemacht habe dann
wären die echt aus wie sein vorgänger
und deswegen habe ich mir ganz spontan
überlegt alle studenten einmal zum
friseur und auf einlass mal wieder ein
bisschen was ich finds echt krass fiel
an die mittlerweile sind also ich kann
sie sogar schon so im mund nehmen fasst
also leute werden wir sehen wie ich
gleich aussehen und danach habe ich noch
ein paar kommentare vorbereitet was so
richtig geile kommentare und natürlich
auch böse kommentare schlechte
kommentare wie scheiße ich doch aussah
mit meinen jetzigen hahn noch unter wert
waren vielleicht mal ein bisschen
kümmern ich meine davos zu fribourg und
dann zeige ich mich gleich nochmals den
ausgleich
[Musik]
was geht ab jetzt sehe ich eigentlich
wieder so aus wie früher
also ich würde sagen vor dem jahr seit
ungefähr torster vor dem halben keine
ahnung auf jeden fall ganz lieb ganz
viel jünger wer unschuldig und überhaupt
nicht so böse und gemein wie ich in
meinen videos rüberkomme
endlich bin ich mal die von jahr leute
ihr habt mit euren ganzen bösen
kommentaren geschafft dass ich das jetzt
wieder so gemacht habe klar das ist
jetzt noch nicht so wie es bald aussehen
wird also die müssen herzen noch ein
bisschen wieder struktur in sich hinein
wachsen wenn man dazu sagen aber ich
könnte meine kommentare schreiben
oder wenn es besser findet als vorher
wovon ich eigentlich ausgehe bin ich mal
gespannt wenn ihr vorher besser findet
dann lasst genau jetzt noch nach unten
da und wenn es jetzt besser findet dann
das doch nach oben da ihr könnt auch
gerne in die kommentare schreiben sonst
arbeitet sich ab obwohl das höchstens
zwei monate her ist man so auf seine auf
jeden fall ich hatte einfach meine haare
nach hinten einfach und dann hatte ich
komplett blonde haare die dann
irgendwann geld wurden auch nach hinten
und über diesen ganzen zeitraum haben
sich natürlich eine menge hält
kommentare angereichert ich will gar
nicht sagen das ist immer nur hält
kommentare waren aber leute waren als
ehrlich und haben richtig richtig
richtig krasse kommentare geschrieben
die mich natürlich sehr getroffen haben
und davon habe ich jetzt einfach mal die
herausgesucht und da haben echte
kommentare wo einfach nur drin steht
deine haare wegen scheiße aus 800 leicht
oder so hat mich sehr mitgenommen zu
hören so der erste kommentar kommt von
anna-lena wie schreibt format von alex
aber die haare passen wirklich nicht das
ist in meinem fall anna lena anna lena
ich denke mal du bist eigentlich die
einzige die das so sei 800 wechsel fand
die leiche
da könnte ich in der auffahrt alles gut
lewitz firma als gut anna lena
jetzt kommt leer heißt irgendwie alle
gleich die lehrer schreibt man man man
bist du hässlich liebl er ich lasse
jetzt mal besser nicht dein youtube bild
in vergrößerte auflösung hier anzeigen
okay wir machen statt es mir einfach mal
schnell weiter jetzt vor was gut ist
deine haare sehnsucht und nochmal
herzlichen herzchen
ich habe mich nicht verliebt kussmund
blablabla scheiße aus man folgt über
instagram kombi zum ersten kommentar der
kommt nicht von theorien sondern von
theresa und wie schreibt irgendwie
machen deine haare dich eltern mit 14
weiß echt nicht im stimmbruch so etwas
schreibt via diese spanische
pornodarsteller frisur stars auch echten
kommentar dann hab ich wirklich so oft
gelesen dass ich aussehe wie ein
spanischer pornodarsteller wo ich mir
dachte hey ich hab echt in meinem leben
noch nie ein spanisches porno gesehen
glaube ich zumindest deswegen wie kommt
er alle darauf ich hab gar keine ahnung
wie ein spanischer pornodarsteller
aussehen soll
ja und auch ein richtig gemeiner
kommentar der sich nur geholfen hat weil
ich diesen malfoy bei harry potter immer
übels hässlich fand dass ich genauso aus
wie der leute mal ganz ehrlich wir
machen jetzt mal kurz im vergleich mit
rein obwohl will ich dann bitte genauso
aus hieraufhin bisschen ähnlichkeit war
da ja gut also ich habe meine haare
wieder getönt ich bin sehr zufrieden
jetzt sehe ich halt echt wieder aus wie
14 15 oder so wartet jetzt vielleicht
nicht aber jetzt jetzt ja ich bin
gespannt gefällt es ist viel würden
jetzt habt ihr bock drauf dann auf jeden
fall lassen und nach oben da falls ja
und auch nach unten falls nein oder
schreibt einfach in die kommentare
wir sehen uns dann an
morgen übermorgen was wir über 50 sind
auf jeden fall wurden wieder keine
ahnung wann aber auf jeden fall morgen
steckt ein wolf netz und ja dann wünsch
euch noch unangenehm tagesschau münchner
dran was jetzt noch immer neuen effekt